Девочка-пай Musik Hallo, das ist das Podcast-Ufo. Wenn ihr Songwünsche habt, ruft sie einfach. Spiel den selben Song nochmal! Alles klar, denselben Song und los!
Hallo, der hat mich Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser Folge, die nie im Leben diesem Intro gerecht werden wird. Auf gar keinen Fall. Herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast-Ufo mit Stefan Titzel und Florentin Will und vielen Dank an dieses fantastische Intro. Es kommt von Flo und seiner zwölfköpfigen Blechbläser-Band Druckluft. Grossartig. Finde ich gut, dass Flo seine Band mal wieder rausgeholt hat. Die hat er geschenkt bekommen, er war zwölf Jahre alt. Dann hat die Mutter immer gesagt, jetzt mach doch mal was mit deiner Blechbläser-Band. Die stehen da immer nur rum und Flo hat gesagt, ja komm, jetzt mach ich mal ein Intro, hau was raus. so fucking stol stolz, Teil dieses Projekt zu sein, wenn halt eine echte Brassband dieses Intro für uns macht. Und es sind aber auch so zehn Prozent Unbehagen dabei, weil ich denke, Flo muss ja zu den Leuten gegangen sein und gesagt haben, ich hab da diesen Podcast gehört mal und hättet ihr vielleicht alle Lust, dieses Intro für mich einzuspielen.
Unmöglich sind ja alle Fans.
Nein, aber ich glaube, so darfst du als Dirigent von so einer Band auch nicht rangehen.
Du meinst, als Leonard Bernstein kannst du auch nicht sagen,
ist nicht jeder Wagner-Fan.
Ich habe hier mal so was geschrieben,
West Side Story, so guckt da mal drüber,
falls da hier und da mal ein paar Noten sind, die euch gefallen,
könnt ihr die gerne, falls ihr Lust habt,
kommt am Wochenende rein. Nein! Gary und mir gefällt es nicht und Leonard Bernstein macht es nicht, nein. Nein. Leonard Bernstein zieht es eiskalt durch. Du gehst hin und sagst, Leute, ich war mal wieder ein fucking Genie am Wochenende und hab na na na na na na na geschrieben, spielt das. Und ich glaube, so ähnlich ist Flo auch, man muss als Bandleader auch mal wirklich durchgreifen können. Vielen, vielen
Dank, fantastisch. Ich bin darüber so
stolz und froh und vielen, vielen Dank.
Dieses Intro entschuldigt die
letzten fünf. Ich würde
sagen, die letzten Hunde.
Da hat Flo und seine Band Druckluft alleine
den Klassenschnitt gehoben. Vielen,
vielen Dank. Ich würde sagen, die
Community als solche hat das
Klassenziel erreicht, weil Flo
nochmal sich richtig reingehängt hat und nochmal
alle Wandbilder gemalt hat
und auch. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich würde sagen, die Community als solche hat das Klassenziel erreicht, weil Flo nochmal sich richtig reingehängt hat und nochmal alle Wandbilder gemalt hat und nochmal für jeden Spieler. Flo hat den Klassenraum aufgeräumt, hat die alten zerrissenen Plakate abgehangen und neue aufgehängt, hat den Steckbrief von jedem nochmal ein bisschen überarbeitet, ein bisschen Pepp mit reingebracht und vielen, vielen Dank. Könnt ihr euch alle bedanken bei Flo. Hat er gemacht. Vielen Dank, Flo, supercool, das freut mich sehr. Aber natürlich auch danke an den Rest der Band. Zwölfköpfig ist natürlich nicht schlecht, aber man muss auch sagen, so eine Blechbläser-Band hat was. Drei mal vier, vier mal drei, sechs mal zwei. Das Gute ist, ich glaube, zwölf ist die perfekte Anzahl einer Gruppe. Ja, du kannst immer sagen, ihr drei macht ... und die anderen macht ... und dann so kann man das gut verteilen. Ja, aber auch so, wenn die mal zusammen wegfahren auf Bandfahrt und so was. Dann gibt's entweder sechs Zweiergruppen, drei Vierergruppen, vier Dreiergruppen, zwei Zweiergruppen. Oder zwölf Einergruppen, je nachdem. Oder zwölf, können nur abhängen. Eine sehr introvertierte Brassband sein. Es ist so eine gut teilbare Zahl, dass wahrscheinlich viele einfach auch Leute finden da, mit denen sie connecten können und nicht unbedingt Leute alleine sind. Also zwölf, denkt vielleicht mal, wenn ihr in einer Gruppe mal startet, mit denen ihr irgendwie loszieht, um die Welt fahrt, dann zwölf, zwölf ist eine gute Zahl. Oder halt als komplettes Orchester mit 64 kannst du auch immer gut teilen, da kannst du zwei Zweiunddreissiger machen, da kannst du gut in verschiedene Teile teilen. Das geht auch immer gut. Hast du die Zahlen, glaubst du, du kannst rechnen oder hast du das auswendig gelernt? Nee, ich will schon rechnen können. Ich habe mir da schon vor mir die Frösche, die über den Teich, also ich habe immer so ein mentales Bild vor mir von Fröschen. Also da ist so ein Teich mit einer Brücke durch in der Mitte und dann sitzen manche Frösche auf der einen Seite der Brücke und manche Frösche auf der anderen Seite. Und wenn ich dann was addiere, dann hüpfen die von der einen Seite des Sees auf die andere Seite über die Brücke und dann zähle ich die nochmal durch. Okay, jetzt mal uns ein Bild für Multiplikation.
Multiplikation hast du dann mehrere Seen.
Mehrere Seen?
Mehrere Seen.
Keine Frösche mehr hingegen.
Doch, in jedem See hast du wieder die beiden Partitionen und hast dann also zum Beispiel acht mal acht wäre acht Seen in jeweils acht Frösche.
Und dann musst du halt durchzählen einmal. Das ist dann schon aufwendig, aber ich glaube, es ist besser,
ursprünglich, es gibt ja Leute, die sagen,
hey, lernt bis hundert einfach alles einmal eins auswendig,
aber ich sage, nein, ich glaube, das Gehirn wird faul,
wenn man auswendig lernt, du musst es dir
auch zusammenbauen können und große Zahlen
auch mal rechnen. Auswendig lernen vergisst man,
ich glaube, Technik rechnen vergisst man nicht,
und ich stand gestern vor der schwierigen
Aufgabe,
60 mal 10,2 und ich habe es nicht hinbekommen. Ich schäme mich bis jetzt. 60 mal 10,2. Das ist unmöglich. Ohne Scheiß. Also mein Froschbild lässt halt auch Kommazahlen schlicht nicht zu. Also da ist einfach ein großes Error. Kaulquappe. Ja, das könntest du machen. So, aber jetzt rechne mal 60 mal 10,2 im Kopf. Und Scheiss, und es war 50 Prozent Anstrengung, 50 Prozent Lachen darüber, dass ich das nicht hinkriege. Ja. Es war schwierig, das waren Auf und Ab, diese zehn Minuten, die ich dafür gebraucht habe. Ja. Weil, das brauchte ich nämlich für meine Bootsprüfung. Ja, es tut mir leid, aber, und da ist kein Taschner zugelassen bei der Prüfung. Da muss man Sachen rechnen wie 10,2 mal 60. Und ich weiß beim besten Willen nicht, wie ich das hinkriegen soll, unter Zeitdruck und Prüfungsangst. Aber Kopfrechnen besteht ohnehin zu 80 Prozent sozialem Druck. Und wie du gerade gesagt hast, 19 Prozent, bin ich wirklich so dumm? Ja. Also, du hörst auf zu rechnen. Ungläubigkeit. Du gehst in den Selbstzweifelraum, machst da die Tür auf, die hat so eine Salon-Tür, da kommt man ganz leicht rein und schwer wieder raus. Man kommt nie wieder raus. Das ist wie so eine Katzenklappe. Du gehst rein und setzt dich da auf deinen Selbstzweifel-Couch und denkst dir, lass mich mal jetzt wirklich intensiv drüber nachdenken, wie unglaublich dumm ich bin, dass ich gerade das nicht hinkriege. Und dann der Barkeeper fragt dann auch so, und wieder das Gleiche, und du sagst, ja, ja, ja, was ist es diesmal, fragt er dann, 10,2 mal 60. Und er schüttelt nur den Kopf und sagt, das weiß niemand, das weiß niemand. Einer hat es mal versucht, aber er ist nie wieder zurückgekommen. 60, und dann habe ich überlegt, gut, 60 mal 10, der Part ist easy, das ist war. Das ist, glaube ich, auch das Problem bei der Rechnung, dass du denkst, ja locker, 60, als du gesagt hast, 60 mal 10, dachte ich mir, das würde ich, glaube ich, noch hinkriegen, aber dann die Komma, das war dann natürlich... Komma zwei, und dann wusste ich ja, 0,2 sind ja, wusste ich sogar, ist ein Fünftel. Aber jetzt rechne mal, 60 durch fünf. Mach das mal wirklich, also... mach das, geh das mal in meinem Kopf durch. 12. Das ist schon Wahnsinn, ne? 12 war far away. 6 und 12 ist die Antwort. Wir waren beide mal in der Schule und konnten Kurvendiskussionen und stokastische Rechnungen und Integrale und finde den Scheitelpunkt und mittlerweile 12, ne? Also, das mal vor, zwölf. Sechzig durch fünf sind zwölf. Das ist schon, also Mathematik kann auch faszinierend sein, ist ja wie eine eigene Sprache, wie eine Kunst eigentlich. Mathematik ist die Kunst, kann man schon noch sagen. Ja, genau wie Blechblasen, vielen Dank nochmal, ich komme immer noch nicht drüber weg, wie fantastisch dieses Info war. Das war fantastisch. Ich finde auch gut, also Blechbläser, die Akzeptanz von Blechblasinstrumenten schwankt bei mir ständig. Natürlich letzte Woche wieder hart erschüttert worden von einem Dinosaurierfund mit der Trompete auf dem Kopf. Mittlerweile haben wir den Eindruck, wie das vielleicht klang, wenn so eine Gruppe Dinosaurier auf die Jagd ging. Vielleicht kann Drucklufter auch mal so den Tanz der Dinosaurier inszenieren. Aber auch alle Tiere, die gejagt werden von diesen Dinosauriern, denken doch auch, fuck yes. Die können gar nicht weglaufen. Und holy shit ist das nervig. Die müssen wegtanzen, die müssen wegtanzen die ganze Zeit. Mit den Jazzhands tanzen die weg. Ja, würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn ein Dinosaurier entdeckt wird, der einfach Jazzhands hat die ganze Zeit.. Aber ich mag Trompeten, Posaunen, ich finde das alles toll. Ich mag auch einfach den Ansatz zu sagen, nee, mein Instrument ist einfach Gold. Farbe golden. Das ist einfach Gold. Also das ist wirklich so. Aber es gibt ja in jedem Orchester immer diese Extravaganzen. Diese Leute, die beschließen, nee, meine Geige ist pechschwarz, nein, mein Kontrabass ist blau, nein, und auch ich wette bei Flo, bei Druckluft, ist auch jemand drin, der hat so eine matt schwarze Trompete. Oder so eine pinke, ja, so ganz auffällig. Was ich nie ganz verstanden habe, weil man macht es auch wegen der Farbe, man macht es auch wegen dieses schönen goldgüldenen Tons. Ja, aber Gold ist halt auch eine schwierige Farbe, weil es ist natürlich die beste Farbe der Welt, klar. Aber es kippt halt auch manchmal, wenn zu viel Gold ist, habe ich das Gefühl. Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel so ein ganzes Auto in Gold hast, dann ist auch das zu viel. Das muss so akzentuiert sein. Oder wenn du dir irgendwie so eine Fantasy-Figur vorstellst, die dann irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, so einen goldenen Umhang trägt oder was auch immer. Kann cool sein, punktuell, aber so die komplette Rüstung in Gold ist dann zu viel.
Und deswegen bin ich bei der Trompete immer so ein bisschen nachhergerissen,
weil ich mir denke, mach doch da so einen coolen goldenen Streifen.
Aber jetzt ist die ja nicht groß, ne? Du hast ja mehr Menschen als Trompete.
Ja, aber so eine Tuba, ich meine, was ist das in Karaten, sage ich.
Ist die Tuba, ist die wahnsinnig teuer?
Ist es auch wieder hier, stimm mal vor, du lernst ein Instrument, und dann ist es das teuerste Instrument der Welt. Stell dir mal vor, eine Harfe, wo immer diese Ornamente dran sind. Und diese im gotischen Stile erbaute Harfe. Und man denkt so, nein, fuck it, ich will, kann ich nicht eine billige, so eine Thoman-Harfe. Ja, ich meine, stell dir vor, du verliebst dich in die Orgel, und dann müssen deine Eltern so eine kleine Kirche ins Zimmer bauen. Eine Kirette Kirchekapelle kaufen. So eine kleine Kapelle irgendwo im Waldrand oder so, wo noch eine kleine Orgel drinsteht, dass du da mal üben kannst, ist schwierig. Ist wahnsinnig schwierig. Mir geht es auch so, ich bin großer Fan der amerikanischen Südstaaten, speziell Norlands. Und auch da ist ja Blechblasen ganz vorne mit dem hohen Kurs.
Ja, natürlich. Ist es nicht Over in the Saints?
Kommt es nicht ursprünglich hin? Klar, natürlich. Wir alle hatten es letzte Woche.
Es ist thematisch perfekt.
Und genau, da ist es zu Hause, diese typische Brassband eigentlich,
diese typische Jazz-Brassband.
Und das ist doch, da macht es total Spaß.
Und es fühlt sich auch für mich immer nach Urlaub. Die Sonne kommt raus, die Leute mit ihren lustigen kleinen Hüten, die zu niedrig sind. Die haben diese Strohüte, ich weiß nicht, was Strohüte sind. Wobei man ja echt aufpassen muss, weil das beißt sich ja komplett. Sonne und eine komplette Band mit extrem reflektierenden goldenen Instrumenten. Also ich glaube, das kann schon wirklich zu einem Massaker führen, wenn die Sonne wirklich rauskommt und die alle da in dem gleisenden Licht untergehen und alle Zuschauer nur noch so ein wabendes, weisses Gebilde sehen und sich abwenden. Die Augen werden ausgebrannt und die Spieler selber völlig desorientiert, Hitzestrahlen von allen Seiten werden durchgekocht. Ist es bei dir auch so, ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann überproportional schlecht Helligkeit wahrnehmen. Ja, mit Helligkeit kommt überhaupt nicht klar. Nee, mir ist häufig so viel zu hell. Aber kann man da nicht so Gesicht Kontaktlinsen? Johnny Depp hatte beim Dreh von Food for Karibik immer Sonnenbrillen-Kontaktlinsen drin. Ja? Kontaktlinsen, die, weil alle, hier, Geoffrey Rush und so, die hatten ja alle gelbe Kontaktlinsen drin, damit sie gefährlicher aussehen. Und Johnny Depp hatte auch Kontaktlinsen drin, obwohl er es nicht braucht, aber halt so Sonnenbrillenkontaktlinsen, damit er halt dunkler sieht und nicht die ganze Zeit geblendet wird und mit zugkniffenen Augen rumläuft. Aber ist das nicht ein bisschen sehr kurzsichtig, weil du ... Oder weitsichtig. Ich meine, du wirst ja dadurch nur noch mehr empfindlicher gegenüber die Sonne. Also das mag vielleicht für einen Drehtag reichen, aber langfristig wird es ja dann noch immer schlimmer. Sind wir nicht irgendwann an der Zeit ... Ich werbe nicht, Johnny Depp zu widersprechen in der Hinsicht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, bitte. Oh, oh, oh, oh, Leute, sorry, das kam jetzt völlig, völlig falsch rüber. Ja, aber das ist Johnny Depp schon bis aus ... Du bist die dritte Spitze. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ihr habt mich völlig falsch verstanden, völlig falsch. Das war jetzt überhaupt keine Kritik an Johnny Depp. Dieses massive Zurückrudern hat man so selten gehört. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, rudert jemand so zurück? Leute, noch mal ganz zurück. Ich fang noch mal ganz von vorne an. Ich habe überhaupt nichts gegen Johnny Depp und seine Entscheidungen, überhaupt nicht. Aber die Frage ist doch, ist das wirklich langfristig eine gute Möglichkeit oder sollten wir nicht als Menschheit letzten Endes sagen, warum soll ich denn die Sonnebrille tragen, warum kann er nicht die Sonne die Sonnebrille tragen? Die Sonnebrille. Und dass wir einfach sagen, NASA und Elsa, Elsa tun sich alle zusammen.
Und Ray-Ban. Und Ray-Ban, die vielleicht grösste Kollaboration unseres Jahrhunderts, NASA meets Ray-Ban, einfach mal der Sonne so eine schöne Sonnenbrille aufzustreifen. So eine coole? Jedes achtjährige Kind hat diese Idee, wenn es die Sonne zeichnet, gibt ihm irgendwie so ein Lächeln, gibt ihm strahl eine Sonnenbrille. Und eigentlich ist es der perfekte Cartoon. Ich finde, Kinder sind mega, also wahnsinnig dumm gemeint natürlich, der Sonne eine Sonnenbrille aufzusetzen. Vielleicht haben wir Kinder verkannt. Und vielleicht, vielleicht sollte man das so machen. Vielleicht sollte man der grossen Sonne, dem Planeten, Stern kann man sagen, eine riesengroße Ray-Ban, so eine Wayfarer-Ausage.
Das ist das Product Placement des Jahrhunderts, oder? Ist das das krasseste Product Placement, das es gibt?
Wird es dann hier, und da habe ich wieder auch viele Grossteile von Astronomie nicht verstanden, wird es dann hier kälter merklich oder nicht?
Oder wird es hier nur, weil die Neuronen schwingen mit den Neutrinos, tanzen den ewigen, die Salzer der Wärme und deswegen wird es hier warm? Ist doch gar nicht das, die Helligkeit ist ja nicht. Ich glaube, es ist Merengue. Also ich bin jetzt auch kein Physikexperter, aber ich glaube, es ist Merengue. Die Neutrinos tanzen den Merengue der Wärme. Protonen tanzen Merengue, Elektronen tanzen Samba. So eine schöne Rumba. Und jetzt frage ich mich aber, wird es deswegen warm oder weil es so hell ist? Er hat Helligkeit, grob was mit Wärme zu tun? Nein. Ich glaube 70-30, 70-30, eins von beiden. Aber es gibt ja auch Helligkeit, die nicht warm ist. Es gibt auch Wärme, die nicht hell ist. Also es gibt Wärme, die nicht hell ist, das glaube ich nicht. Naja, ist eine Heizung?
Nee, aber so im kosmischen Kontext glaube ich.
Gut, wenn du im KK bist, dann da kann ich nicht mitkommen.
Ich weiß noch im Wohnzimmerkontext. Du bist im WK, ich will im Kaka. Und da muss man schon sagen, dass Energie häufig hell ist. Je mehr Energie fragegesetzt wird, desto heller. Ja gut, aber Schwarzes Loch ist natürlich das exakte Gegenbeispiel. Ich weiß nichts. Nee, du weißt nichts. Wir wissen nichts, außer dass wir ein fantastisches Intro haben. Ja, das Intro war toll. Das war richtig toll. Immer wenn ich mir solche Bands vorstelle, stelle ich mir auch vor, dass die so eine Choreo haben mit ihren Trompeten. Und immer so links, rechts, oben und links, rechts. Weil Trompeten sind Energie. Und da sind zum Beispiel Hafen und auch teilweise Geigen voraus. Geigen nicht mehr so stark, weil da auch Bewegung drin ist. Aber ich finde, du hörst so ein Album, wo zwischendurch so Brass-Hits drin sind oder mal so Filz, du hörst da so eine Energie raus. Weil du siehst einfach die fünfköpfige Brass-Crew hinten, siehst du die Instrumente in die Höhe regnen. Wenn wir diese Energie nutzen könnten zur Stromerzeugung von Blechbläsern, wenn wir es irgendwie schaffen könnten, diese enorme Energiequelle anzuzapfen. Also bist du nicht weitergekommen. Du bist nicht weitergekommen mit deiner wochenlang andauernden Idee, aus irgendwas muss man noch Elastität erzeugen können. Nein, ich dachte, erst dachte ich irgendwie an Wolken, dass man Wolken, weil die können ja fliegen anscheinend, dass man da irgendwie versucht, irgendwas dran zu hängen an der Wolke, dass man die einfängt mit einem grossen Netz oder mit einer Plastiktüte und die dann, weil die ziehen ja vorbei oder dreht sich die Erde. Dreht sich die Erde weg von Wolken. Die Wolken bleiben konstant am Himmel. Ja, das kann auch sein, aber dass man da dann irgendwie so eine Turbine an, also du wickelst so ein langes Seil um so eine Turbine, hängst das Seil dann an die Wolke und die Wolke zerrt dann an dem Seil und dreht dann die Turbine an, aber es hat halt überhaupt nicht geklappt.
Also das hat wirklich, also der Baumarkt hatte zu, ich konnte keine Materialien kaufen, ich hatte das Seil war halt irgendwie, das Seil war nicht mal drei Meter lang, also es hat wirklich, glaube ich, an wirklich jedem Element dieses Plans hat es gemangelt. Aber es muss doch schon mal jemand auf die Idee gekommen sein. Und deswegen habe ich es noch nie gepitcht. Im Fitnessstudio alle Geräte an so einem grossen, was in so Windmühlen drin ist, in diesen Windrädern, was Energie speichert. So ein Akku. Aber wird damit nicht dieser eine Monitor betrieben, auf dem immer wieder Komen der Barbar läuft den ganzen Tag? Genau, es läuft die ganze Zeit, ne, NTV ist glaube ich neu. Ruhe die Nachrichten! Es läuft die ganze Zeit NTV in Fitnessstudios, deswegen ist ja immer so eine bedrückende Stimmung. Und ich glaube, wenn man das aber ausmacht, mal NTV runter, mal Licht aus und dann mal sagt, nee, alle Geräte erzeugen jetzt Strom und man hat so einen grossen, also ein grosses Akku unten drunter im Keller liegen, dann glaube ich, kann man schon viel Strom erzeugen. Ja, ich glaube, das Problem ist halt, dass du massiv unterschätzt, wie viel Energie da tatsächlich rumkommt, weil die meisten Leute ja die Geräte nicht benutzen, sondern sich hinsetzen. Ich glaube,
dieses Drehkreuz für Ein- und Ausgang,
da entsteht am meisten Energie von Leuten, die in das Wittnisstück
reingehen und wieder rausgehen.
Das kannst du anzapfen. Und das wütende Drücken
auf das Abmeldung des Newsletters.
In den Mails. Ja, da ist so viel
Kraft in diesem Klick, das kannst du machen.
Aber du hast schon recht,
wenn ich jetzt was anderes sage, die Erdrotationen müssen ja enorme Energien herrschen, weil die Erde ist ja riesig und schwer und die dreht sich ja recht schnell, 24 Stunden für eine Drehung ist schon nicht schlecht, da kann man nicht das irgendwie nutzen, dass man da irgendwie so ein Fähnchen ins Wind hängt oder. Spämmllen ist kein Wind, ne? Ja, aber an einem Fixpunkt
oder so, dass man irgendwie... Und ganz ehrlich, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie viel Energie dahinter steckt, weil
im Weltall ist ja auch kein
Widerstand.
Im Weltall hört dich niemand schreien.
Ja, aber du hast ja trotzdem Masse, mal Geschwindigkeit,
ist ja egal, du hast ja trotzdem Energie.
Foucault'sche Pendel zum Beispiel, so wenn du so einen Pendel hast
und das dann, 24
später hat es ja sich einmal gedreht,
weil das sozusagen unabhängig von der Erdrotation.
So was meine ich, kann man da nicht
Vielen Dank. Pendel zum Beispiel, so wenn du so einen Pendel hast und das dann, 24 später hat es ja sich einmal gedreht, weil das sozusagen unabhängig von der Erdrotation, so was meine ich, kann man da nicht, weil da ist ja auch eine Energie drin, dass sich das einmal dreht. Und du glaubst, dass Foucault bis dahin gedacht und danach hat er aufgehört. Ja, schließt seine Turbine an, Foucault. Was machst du denn, Michel? Was ist das denn immer? Ich glaube ja, Perpetuum mobile muss ja funktionieren. Ja, glaube ich auch. Also da sind wir uns ja einig. Da sind wir uns ja eigentlich einig, dass das die Idee sein muss. Es gibt ja eine komplette Perpetuum mobile Forschung, wo andere Physiker seit Jahren sagen, Leute, das geht nicht, aber die sagen, nee, aber es muss doch gehen. Es muss doch irgendwie gehen. Ja, wir sind unser Sonnensystem nicht schon so eine Art Perpetuum mobile. Wir drehen uns so lange schon, seit ich denken kann, drehen wir uns schon rum. Immer gleich, immer werden gleich. Seit wann kannst du denken? Ja, gute Frage. Was würdest du sagen, waren so deine Top-3-Gedanken, die du je hattest? Top-3-Gedanken? Was du auch das ganze Leben zurück projiziert, wo du sagst, wow, das war ein guter Gedanke, habe ich mal gut gedacht heute. Platz drei, warum werden in Fitnessstudios nicht einfach alle Geräte an so einen grossen Akku angeschlossen? Ja, der war gut. Wann war der? Der war 1998? 1998, zweiter Gedanke, Top zwei, ach nee, das geht ja nicht aufgrund zu geringer Akkuleistung. Ja, das war gerade eben. Das war gerade eben. Und jetzt gerade habe ich gedacht, da habe ich den besten Gedanken. Nee, müsste ja doch jetzt gehen, weil Tesla ja jetzt auch große Akkus rausgebracht hat. Da war doch was mit Brandenburg. Wo liegt nochmal Brandenburg? Ah ja, bei Berlin. Ja, das war dein bester Gedanke. Das war mein bester Gedanke, ja. Finde ich schön. Nee, ich bin aber auch gerade lediert. Ich habe meine Weisse-Hände rausbekommen. Oh, stimmt, ja. Ich klinge so ein bisschen so, wie ihr das vielleicht merkt. Bisschen bieberig. Ein bisschen bieberig, ich habe dicke Backen und so ein Hamster. Leider Gottes ist bei mir nicht ganz doll angeschwellt. Ich dachte erst, man will ja die grosse Schwellung, will man nicht. Man will sie aber doch, weil die grosse Schwellung sagt allen, ah, der hat seine Weisheit-Hände rausbekommen. Meine Schwellung sagt, oh, der hat zehn Küche zugenommen. Das ist halt auch nicht cool. Also ich dachte, man will das, aber man will es nicht. Man will die krasse Schwellung haben, man will die auch sofort aufhörtern. Man will die lächerlich karikaturenhafte Schwellung, wo jeder sieht, oh, der ist in einem Ausnahmezustand. Ah, okay, der hat eine Weisheitshände rausbekommen. Ich muss gerade sein Aussehen nicht bewerten, der ist gerade in einem Ausnahmezustand. Genau, ich muss gerade ihn nicht, aber stattdessen werde ich wahrgenommen, das merke ich auch in der Öffentlichkeit, als hässlicherer Mensch als ich sonst bin. Aber jetzt lass uns über Schwellung reden, weil hast du, wenn deine Wangen geschwollen sind, hast du dann auch mehr Platz im Mund? Oder werden die Wände dann dicker oder was? Ich habe nicht, es wird alles ein bisschen härter und dicker. Ich glaube, die Wände werden dicker. Aber das ist ja ganz dünn, oder? Also so die Wange selber ist ja ganz dünn. Wie kann die denn dicker werden? Ich habe ja vier auf einmal rausbekommen und die Vorstellung ist so eklig. Und ich war, Gott sei Dank, hatte ich eine Vollnarkose bekommen müssen, weil die so komisch auch lagen. Und ich war so froh. Und der Arzt danach, das erste Mal, nachdem ich aufgewacht bin, hat auch gesagt, seien Sie froh, dass Sie eine Vollachkose hatten, das war furchtbar. Ich habe zweimal den Mülleimer gekocht. Das war die Hölle. Das war die Hölle. Das war die absolute Hölle. Und dann noch so blutbeschmierte Kittel, das war wirklich das war hart und dann die flexen die auch auf und dann drücken die so ganz furchtbar. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, keine Details. Nee, aber jetzt, also, Vollnachkurs ist ja auch fantastisch, ne? Ich hab dann so grob mein Gewicht gesagt, die hat gefragt, wie viel ich wiege, wollte sie aber nicht, dann hab ich einfach irgendwas gesagt, wo ich glaube, dass es stimmt, und dann hat die mir einfach so einen Cocktail da reingeballert in den Arm, und du merkst, ich find's immer wieder faszinierend, wenn so langsam dein Kopf warm wird und du merkst, irgendeine Substanz fließt durch deine Venen und du bist weg. Du kannst da nichts dagegen machen. Beim Einschlafen kannst du dich ja aktiv wach halten, aber da halt nicht. Ja, aber du glaubst es bis zu dem Moment, glaubst du es nicht. Ich bin da hingefahren zum Zahnarzt und habe diesen Hypnose funktioniert nicht Gedanken gehabt, diesen Ansatz, dieses ja, wenn ich nicht daran glaube, funktioniert auch nicht, so dieses, wie wollt ihr das hinkriegen, ich bin gleich weg, ich kann ja wohl selbst entscheiden, wann ich einschlafe und bei Bewusstsein bin, und dann kriegst du dieses Ding rein und man denkt, nein. Nein, ich hatte auch keine Kontrolle gehabt.
Keine Kontrolle gehabt, nee, überhaupt nicht.
Und das ist nämlich faszinierend, super gruselig, aber auch zugleich finde ich immer diese totale Kontrollaufgabe.
Kontrollverlust ist ja eh meine grosse Angst, top drei Ängste, alle Kontrollverlust, aber ich habe es überstanden und jetzt geht es wieder gut. Und jetzt habe ich nämlich ganz viel Antibiotikum und Schmerztabletten. Aber kriegt man, hast du die Weisheitszellen auch bekommen, kriegt man die dann? Die sind ja so komplett kaputt. Das war auch meine Frage, das war auch meine Frage, Ich glaube, wurde nicht beantwortet. Ich glaube, weil die nicht kaputt sind. Die ist gefragt und der Arzt ist einfach gegangen. Hat es so weggewunken. Ja, wie ich war bei meiner Zahnspange, als ich hatte eine Zahnspange, aber hinten die Spange, also nicht vorne an den Zähnen, wo man sie sieht, wo man sich die klassische feste Zahnspange vorstellt, sondern ich hatte sie hinten. Und da ja auch die Zunge ist, muss das ein Metall sein, das sehr weich ist, damit deine Zunge nicht kaputt geht. Und ein weiches Metall ist ja Gold. Und Gold ist ja nebenbei auch noch recht wertvoll. Und das heißt, du hast ja Gold im Mund. Und als mir die rausgenommen wurde, habe ich dann auch gesagt so, was passiert denn jetzt mit dem Gold? Und die auch so Augen rollen und, ja, das können sie nicht mitnehmen.
Fuck, fuck, hell.
Das ist immer so wahrscheinlich so.
Deswegen machen die das.
Ja, denen wurde wahrscheinlich gesagt, wenn der Patient das Gold nicht will, kriegt die Kieferorthopäden Assistenten.
Der will ja kein Gold. Das ist um Menschen, das ist um Menschen nicht Gold zu wollen.
Aber dann, falls ihr euch jetzt fragt, Moment mal, Florentin besitzt Gold, aber er wirkt gar nicht so abgehoben, unangenehm, reich eigentlich.
Was ist denn mit dem Gold passiert?
Ich habe es eingeschmolzen für dein Trompetenprojekt. Wie viele Trompeten kriege ich aus? Ich glaube, es waren sieben Gramm. Ich glaube, das sind schon ein paar hundert Euro, aber es könnten halt auch ein paar Trompeten sein. Könnte ich ja spenden eigentlich an Druckluft, damit der eine, der mit Ronny mit seinem hässlichen matt, matt schwarzen Posaunen-Ungetüben endlich mal einen guten Anstrich.
So eine Goldlegierung aus seinen Zähnen.
Weil bei meinem Nachbar wurde eingebrochen, Nachbar wurde eingebrochen, schon vor einiger Zeit.
Aber eigentlich wollten sie zu dir und dein Goldzähnchen.
Ich denk's mir nämlich, ich lag in der Badewanne und hör nur Rumoren im Treppenhaus und dann so Polizei, war Polizei da und ich lag halt in der Badewanne heiß aufgebläht und dachte mir, bitte klopft nicht bei mir, bitte, bitte klingelt nicht bei mir. Ich kann jetzt keine Zeugenaussage machen, wenn ich gerade, vor allem wenn du, mein Bad ist recht klein und da ist halt einfach, wenn da heißes Wasser drin ist, ist halt das wie eine Sauna einfach, Die Luftfeuchtigkeit ist hoch, es ist so eine schwitzige, schwüle, unangenehme Situation. Aber es ist nicht immer so, wir stellen uns doch immer Situationen vor, die wir aus Filmen kennen. Polizei ist nebenan, befrag dich. Zeus, ja. Zeus. Olymp. Man sitzt auf dem Olymp und straft die Menschen. Aber es gibt so viele Szenen, wo man sich so als Held vorstellt und so.
Und dann ist aber, da kommt mal so eine Situation, Polizei, nebenan. Haben sie was gesehen und du hast vielleicht sowas gesehen, aber hast halt nichts an in dem Moment. Oder bist halt aufgefallen, aufgedunsen in der Wanne. Oder hast halt so, weil du gerade Pretty Woman schaust, so von Weinen unterlegte Augen. Genau. Ja, das kann sein und ich dachte mir, wenn die aufmachen, nicht nur wenn ich die Tür aufmache, quillt denen einfach so eine schwedische Sauna entgegen. Ich bin auch noch absolut tiefenentspannt. Also ich bin nicht die Stimmung, die die Polizei wollen. Du bist wie so ein Serienkiller. Weil die waren halt wirklich so, das war halt direkt nach dem Einmach und ich habe wirklich gehört, okay, Sie müssen jetzt erstmal sagen, wohin ist der gegangen, wie sah der aus, wie viele? weil die waren wirklich so, der Streifenwagen steht ein Blaulicht vor der Tür, wir fangen den jetzt. Das ist jetzt nicht diese... Haben Sie fangen gesagt? Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie fangen, ich glaube, wir wollen den jetzt hinterher wetzen, glaube ich, war die Polizei, die haben Fachbegriffe. Und es war wirklich so eine, wir reden gleich entspannt, aber jetzt können wir ihn noch fangen, jetzt müssen wir los. Da dachte ich mir, wenn die jetzt bei mir klären ist. Du bist entspannt, du bist der Situation nicht angemessen. Was haben Sie gesehen? Erst mal, ich kann das gar nicht vertragen. Kommen Sie erst noch ein bisschen runter. Ich habe so einen Yogi-Tee. Ich habe eine große Badewanne. Darf man eigentlich jemandem nackt die Tür aufmachen oder ist das verboten? Ich glaube, es ist verboten. Aber darf man in seiner eigenen Wohnung nicht machen, was man will? Weil du darfst ja in deiner eigenen Wohnung nackt sein. Ich glaube, wenn es andere sehen können. Ich glaube, wenn andere, deswegen musst du ja dann so mit so einem Lineal und so einem Sextant musst du durch deine Wohnung laufen, um zu gucken, welche Winkel einsehbar sind von Nachbarn. Immer auf Genitalhöhe musst du die Fenster abchecken und genau auf der Höhe abkleben mit so Pixelfolie. Das ist, glaube ich, die Idee. Ich weiß es gar nicht, aber angenommen, man würde der Polizei nackt die Tür aufmachen, verhaften die einen dann direkt? Oder sagen die, ziehen sich bitte erst was an? Oder ziehen die dir dann an? Ich weiss es nicht. Ich denke mir generell, was ist das Protokoll, wenn die halt diesen, die wollen den Räuber fangen. Prioritäten, eisermann. Aber die haben ja Prioritäten. Und dann merken die aber, oh, bei dir brennt da hinten noch ein Joint, zum Beispiel. Ja. Oder der ist nackt in der Wohnung. Moment, wo reizt sich das dann ein? Heisser Marihuana-Dampf schwillt mir entgegen. Ich denk mir das immer, wenn jetzt ein Polizeiwagen einen Räuber fangen will mit einem Auto, und dann fahren die aber plötzlich jemandem Spiegel ab. Müssen die dann nicht erst mal den Unfallort sichern, oder müssen die dann erst mal da den Zettel dran kleben? Oder ist denen das scheißegal, und die haben die andere Priorität und verfolgen den Dieb weiterhin? Ich weiß es nicht. Alles, was ich weiß, ist, dass sie tatsächlich nicht bei mir geklingelt haben. Zum Glück, ich lag entspannt in der Badewanne, dachte mir dann aber, okay, zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder, ich muss jetzt Angst haben, dass bei mir auch eingebrochen wird, oder ich muss gerade nicht Angst haben, dass bei mir eingebrochen wird. Weil ich als Einbrecher ... Das sind auch die beiden Gedanken, die ich immer habe. Ehrlich gesagt. In diesem Spannungsfeld bewegt sich mein Leben. Und ehrlich gesagt, mir geht es gut in diesem Spannungsfeld. Ja, weil als Einbrecher würde ich ja nicht noch mal in demselben Haus einbrechen, wo ich schon eingebrochen habe. Ja, vor allem wenn die Polizei literally im Haus ist. Die lauern, ja, die lauern direkt. Und dann bin ich aber danach nach Hamburg gefahren und dachte mir, komm, sei vernünftig und versuch doch zumindest deine wertvollsten Sachen in Sicherheit zu bringen. Und dann habe ich meinen Kleingeld Eimer in Sicherheit gebracht. Ich sage nicht wo, keine Chance Leute, keine Chance. Und ich habe meine Goldzähne, meine Goldzahnspangenteile, meine sieben Gramm Gold, habe ich versteckt in meiner Wohnung. Dann kam ich aus Hamburg zurück, nichts wurde geklaut, wusste aber nicht mehr genau, wo ich die versteckt habe. Du bist wie Eichhörnchen. Eichhörnchen verstecken Nüsse und das ist ja die Idee der Bäume. Dass seine Bäume wachsen, wo die die vergessen haben. Genau. Die Bäume wollen das nämlich, dass sie das vergessen, die planen das ein. Das ist immer so ein bisschen so eine Toleranzgrenze eingebaut. Aber exakt so ist es bei mir, falls irgendwann so ein Goldbaum bei mir aus dem Bücherregal quillt, weiß ich was los ist. Aber momentan bin ich meines Goldes verlustig und ich weiß nicht, wo es ist, aber ich brauche es momentan zum Glück auch nicht. Aber es ist schon unangenehm. Aber es ist auch so ein kleiner Satzschul. Weil vor allem das Problem ist, wenn du jetzt eine Schatzsuche machst und du hast so eine Landkarte, dann musst du, okay, der große Pirat Blackbeard, Longbeard. Und dann versuchst du dich in den Reihen zu denken, wie denkt so ein Piratenkapitän, wie denkt so ein Typ, weil es ist eher ein Haudegen, es ist ein Draufgänger. Und wenn du aber nach deinen eigenen Goldzählen... Das weitere Spannungsfeld übrigens, ist es ein Haudegen oder ein Draufgänger, es ist ein anderes Spannungsfeld zwischen... Sie brechen bei mir ein oder auf gar keinen Fall bei mir ein. Große Identitätskrise für jeden Piraten, wo verorte ich mich auf dieser Skala? Aber wenn du nach deinen eigenen Goldzählen suchst, du versuchst ja, wie habe ich gedacht? Was denke ich? Wie hat der grosse Florentin Rothbart gedacht. Wo würde ich selbst hier in dem Buch, habe ich gedacht, habe ich einen Gag gemacht und irgendwie so ein Buch genommen, in dem es um Gold geht, der Gold. Und dann, ach nee. Ich kenne gar keine Bücher. Ach ja, erst mal Essen machen. Erst mal Reis kochen. Erst mal so einen ganzen Beutel Reis kochen. Aber ich weiß, das Thema nervt dich. Aber wo wir gerade bei Schatzsuche waren und auf zur See fahren, ich habe jetzt klischee-mäßig, was sehr lustig ist, weil es ja an jedem Punkt meiner Phasen oder auch, sagen wir mal, generell von Hobbys immer diesen Punkt gibt, wo man sagt, man verliert so ein bisschen die Sicht und warum hat man das nochmal angefangen? Man fährt in den Nebel. Man fährt in den Nebel. Und dann bereitet sich auf die Prüfung vor und man denkt, warum hat das nochmal nervt, Prüfung vorbereiten nervt. Aber dann kam der Moment, wo ich die Navigationsaufgaben üben musste. Und mit diesem Zirkel und dieser riesig lächerlich großen Seekarte. Die hast du aber. Die habe ich, die braucht man nämlich zum Lernen. Aber von welchem Bereich ist diese Seekarte? Die ist aus dem Mündungsbereich, danke, dass du fragst, Weser, Elbe und Jade. Der Mündungsbereich oben Nordsee, da sind auch noch ein paar ostfriesische Inseln dabei. Das ist die Übungskarte, die man benutzen muss zum Lernen für die Navigationsaufgaben für den Sportbootführerschein See. So, dann hast du da so ein großes Kursdreieck, so wie so ein Geodreieck, wo da ein Winkel draufstehen, weil du ja Kurse in Winkelmessungen einzeichnest. Du hast dann diesen Zirkel, mit dem du dann auch Seemeilen abläufst. Den auch schon Barbossa benutzt hat, by the way. Den fucking Barbossa und Captain Jack Sparrow benutzt hat. Und man fühlt sich so geil damit. Und ich habe mich gestern so gefreut, das zu üben endlich. Aber was genau bedeutet Navigation? Also wenn du sagst, ich will von hier nach Rügen, dann planst du deine Strecke und weißt dann, okay, nach einer Stunde muss ich so und so viel Winkel nach links? Nee? Nee, es geht darum, wie schnell fährst du, wo, wo willst du hin und dann geht es darum, den Winkel abzumessen, weil das ist immer anders. Wenn dein Kompass auf deinem Schiff zeigt zum magnetischen Norden, das ist aber nicht zwangsläufig Norden auf der Karte, das ist der magnetische Kompasskurs und der rechtsweisende Kurs. Und du willst ja, das ist der Kurs auf der Karte, wo Norden ganz oben ist. Das heißt, du musst so ein paar immer ein bisschen rechnen und dann hat auch noch ein Schiff immer so eine Ablenkung, wenn du halt irgendwo Eisen an Bord hast, lenkt das auch den Kompass noch ab. Dann musst du halt die Ablenkung wissen und sowas. Und deswegen musst du so ein paar Formeln halt haben und so ist alles nicht so kompliziert. Moment, Moment, warum, wenn das Schiff aus Eisen ist, dann lenkt es das Magnetfeld um, oder? Ne, dann lenkt es den Kompass an Bord ab ein bisschen, immer so ein paar Grad. Und deswegen musst du immer umrechnen zwischen dem, was der Kompass anzeigt und dem, wie du den Kurs auf der Karte anzeigst. Und das ist total cool, aber zu rechnen, wo ist man ungefähr
in einer halben Stunde und so. Und dann geht's
auch darum, du musst peilen zum Beispiel, wenn du
da diesen Leuchtturm siehst, auf
285 Grad und da hinten siehst
du eine Tonne, die blinkt auf und du kannst
sie bestimmen auf der Karte auf
70 Grad und dann kannst du die beiden Striche
verbinden und siehst genau, wo du bist.
Hast deinen Punkt. Du hast ohne
GPS, ohne dein fucking Handy,
hast du einfach durch Peilung,
weißt du, wo du gerade bist
Vielen Dank. und siehst genau, wo du bist, hast deinen Punkt. Du hast ohne GPS, ohne dein fucking Handy, hast du einfach durch Peilung,
weißt du, wo du gerade bist.
Und das ist doch befriedigend, das ist doch einfach total cool.
Ich fühle mich wie Captain Jack Sparrow und denke mir die ganze Zeit,
das ist mein Leben jetzt.
Aber wenn du jetzt auf dem Schiff stehst, wie kommst du auf diese 270 Grad?
Hast du da so eine Art ...
Das ist ein Peilkompass.
Ein Peilkompass, also du guckst da durch, oder was?
Ja, ein Peilkompass ist, glaube ich, einfach ... Es gibt normale Kompasse, die kannst du oben so ein Ding aufklappen, da kannst du dann durchgucken. Ach, wie so Kimme und Korn kannst du dann auf das Ziel richten. Genau, oder das kannst du festhalten wie so eine Knarre und da ist oben so eine Kugel drauf. Das ist schon ziemlich cool, ehrlich gesagt. Und da fängt es auch an, dann richtig Spaß zu machen. Sind teilweise sehr komplexe Aufgaben, weil man auch nicht viel Zeit hat. Meine Reaktion kippt auch gerade bei deinem Segelschein von Verachtung in Neid. In ab und tiefen Neid. Ja, und ich bin auch so ein großer Futter-Lebik-Fan, weil ich auch dieses ganze Seeding total cool finde. Ja, alles daran ist auch geil, dieses zu See fahren. Und ehrlich gesagt, diese Vorstellung, mal alleine mit einem Boot rauszufahren, auf offener See und nichts um sich herum zu haben. Aber bist du auch interessiert, da ein Spektrum zu erweitern über Fluch der Gräbig hinaus? Nee. So Master and Commander mal? Null. The Terror oder so? Gar kein Interesse. Ich glaube, The Terror wird dir gefallen. Okay. Ich glaube, The Terror, die fahren mit zwei Schiffen durch die Antarktis durch, wollen da einen Seeweg finden durchs Eis, richtig cool. Ich kann empfehlen All is Lost mit Robert Redford. Ja, den habe ich auch gesehen, ja. Aber sollte man sich den anschauen, ist es auch beim Segelschein gehört, dass er zu Lektion eins schaut, euch folgende Filme bitte nicht an. Doch, man muss erst All is Lost mit Robert Redford schauen. Und wenn man dann noch Bock hat, kriegt man den aber relativ easy, den Schein. Die hätten, glaube ich, grosse Probleme, noch Leute zu finden, die Bootscheine machen wollen nach All is Lost. Ja, das stimmt. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch immer so eine Schwankung. Ich glaube, die sind wahrscheinlich nicht so die krassen Siniasten da in diesem Bootsamt, aber die kriegen wahrscheinlich immer so die Wellenbewegung mit von, ah, ist gerade ein Film, ja, Weisse High, fuck! Weisse High, alles droppt und dann geht es wieder hoch. Das kann schon sein. Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht. Ich bin in All is Lost reingegangen, dachte mir, Happy-go-lucky-Film.
Warum dachtest du das denn?
Aber der hat ja alles verloren dann.
In gewisser Weise, ja.
Der hat dann doch auf eine Art alles verloren.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Aber ich hätte ja schon Respekt zu ganz alleine auf der See,
weil ich denke, wenn du ganz alleine bist und dann kommt niemand. Und man lernt auch, man kann die See, ein Seemann bezwingt die See nicht, er passt sich nur an die Verhältnisse an, er versucht es zu überqueren, er versucht, der See immer Respekt zu zollen und sie überqueren. Aber ein echter Seemann bezwingt nicht die See. Was man das sagen muss, die erste Lektion, Stefan, ich will die See bezwingen. Nein, Lektion eins, ein echter Seemann bezwingt nicht die See. Das weiß ich auch, als ich damals als Kind Karate gelernt habe, hat auch mein Sensei gesagt, wir lernen Karate, um es niemals anzuwenden. Ja, ciao, das war es von mir. Ich bin raus. Ich mache jetzt Judo. Bei Judo, wir lernen Judo, um Leuten mal so richtig in die Fresse zu hauen. Um einfach die Fresse zu polieren. Das macht auch Spaß, Leute. Judo, Judo, Judo. Ja, aber finde ich auch gut, so diese Bescheidenheit. Auch im Dart-Kurs, wir lernen Dart, um niemals 180 zu werfen. Weil klar, Gladiatron-Kämpfe sind scheiße, machen wir uns nicht vor. Ja, die sind ein bisschen, nee, muss nicht sein. Ich finde es martialisch. Es muss nicht sein, ist out. Ist das unser Out der Woche? Out der Woche Gladiatorn. Ja, warte, warte, warte. Ach so, okay. Angenommen, die wären noch möglich. Ja. Einfach mal den besten Judoka antreten lassen gegen den besten Karatekämpfer. Aber ist das nicht MMA? Und dann mal gucken, was passiert. Ich glaube, genau das ist MMA. Dass so verschiedene Kampfkunstarten ... Aber die können ja auch jeweils unter sich ... Da kann ja der eine auch plötzlich einen Karate-Move machen. Ja, das stimmt. Oder so eine Judo-Karate-Kombo. Das Problem, der Nachteil von MMA gegenüber Gladiatorenkämpfen ist, du hast halt auch keinen Löwen. Weil das ist halt schon die Frage, welcher Kämpfer kommt am besten mit dem Löwen klar? Der Judoka, der halt den dann so über die Schulter wirft? Oder Karate, der ihm halt so direkt ins Gesicht boxt? Ich bin ein bisschen vorangenehm bei Judo auch. Aber da geht es ja nicht darum, nur irgendwie cool hinzufallen und sich abzurollen und so. Ja, aber das kann schon auch cool sein. Und der Löwe denkt sich, I don't fucking care, ich fress dich auf, jam jam jam. Und bei Karate kriegt er auf den Deckel? Nein, nein, nein, jeder weiß, auch Grosskatzen besiegt man, indem man sie auf den Rücken wirft und ihnen dann den Bauch reibt. Und dann freuen die sich und dann freuen die sich und dann batz kann man sie erwürgen. Ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Möglichkeit. Aber was wäre denn so die, welche Sportler würde dann gewinnen, wenn du sagst, auf Leben und Tod, ihr dürften nur Moves eures, nee, gegeneinander. Ich glaube, Muay Thai ist da immer hoch dabei irgendwie, aber ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Haben die so einen Stock? Die kriegen zwei Stöcke, ja. Die kriegen zwei Stöcke. Die haben so eine Kugel an so einer Kette, haben die anderen und die anderen haben dann so wie Raffaello diese zwei kleinen Spieße, die auch super uncool sind. Aber lecker. Ja, aber richtig lecker. Bei Schaschlik ist der natürlich ganz freundlich. Hat bei dir eigentlich die Grillsaison angefangen? Würde mich interessieren, weil du hast ja mal erzählt letztes Jahr, du hast ja einen Grill besorgt, du bist ja ohnehin kulinarisch bewandert, wurde da schon ordentlich Grillgut verzehrt? Ne, dass du fragst, dieses Wochenende wurde angegrillt. Ja, angegrillt! Ich habe schön Lachs auf den Grill gehauen, weil ich konnte ja sonst nichts essen. Ich kann ja keine Sachen essen gerade, deswegen habe ich mir so einen schönen, so einen butterzarten, weichen Lachs. Ich glaube, ich wurde extrem verarscht auch in dem Laden, für sehr viel Geld gekauft, aber so ein großes Stück und einfach auf dem Grill. Und ehrlich gesagt, das ist perfekt mit Knoblauch, Salz, Pfeffer. Es ist perfekt. Ich liebe, liebe, liebe Lachs. Aber gibt es auch Beilagen bei dir? Also darf man sich dann auch mal über so eine Kartoffel? Keine Beilagen. Man darf sich darüber nicht freuen, nein. Gar nicht. Mal so eine Grillkartoffel auch dazu? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Und das ist doch auch, woher kommt denn diese Flut, diese Beilagenflut, wie ich sie nenne? Ich habe gehört, also so wurde mir das erklärt, dass man zu Fisch immer Kartoffeln essen muss, damit man, wenn man eine Gräte im Hals hat, damit die durch die Kartoffel besiegt wird. Der grösste Feind der Gräte sind so weiche, weichgekaute Kartoffeln. Aber so habe ich das wirklich, ich weiß nicht, ob mir meine Eltern das erklärt haben, weil da gab es immer Fisch und Kartoffeln. Und dann hieß es, ja, weil ich weiß nicht, ob da noch Gräten drin sind. Und wo ich mir auch schon als Kind dachte, ja, dann essen wir halt einfach was anderes, einen Schnitzel oder so. Wir müssen ja nicht das essen, was uns potenziell umbringt. Aber gut, ich bin ein Kind, ich kann mir mein Essen nicht aussuchen. Ich esse das, was kommt. Ich bin ein Kind, meine Meinung ist da noch nicht so weit entwickelt. Ja, das stimmt. Mir fehlt da auch Erfahrung. Ja, ich habe eine Meinung, aber sag sie nicht, was vielleicht gar nicht schlecht ist. Und ja, genau so sind Kinder. Und dann habe ich gelernt, dass sozusagen, weil ich habe damals viel Pokémon gespielt und habe das Konzept von Schwäche und Resistenz verstanden, gewisse Dinge sind gut gegeneinander.
Und weiss auch, was gegen Wasser-Pokémon gewinnt.
Genau, und dachte mir, aha, also Fisch haben schwäche Kartoffel sozusagen mit ihrer Gräzenattacke.
Und so ein schönes Mirabla kann ja auch mal gewinnen.
Ja.
Was ist das kartoffelähnlichste Ultrigarier?
Kann gewinnen gegen Goldini. Ja, genau. Ich glaube, das ist ja auch wirklich eine gute Möglichkeit. Und so habe ich gelernt, du brauchst immer Kartoffeln, eher so als Notkartoffel, also gar nicht als Genussmittel, sondern nur als Arznei, dass wenn du eine Gräte im Hals hast und kurz vor dem Ersticken bist, rettet dich die Kartoffel. So habe ich es gelernt, deswegen habe ich mir kurz Sorgen gemacht um deinen Lachs, aber ich glaube, Lachs ist technisch eh nicht so ein Problem. Kein Problem, ich glaube auch, dass ich glaube, es kommt daher, dass man sagt, man braucht Proteine, Lachs hat Proteine, dann brauchst du auch Kohlenhydrate und Fett und so und so bildet sich dann so langsam so ein Gericht im klassischen Sinne. Ich sage, Beilagen gehören abgeschafft. Weg mit dem Brot, mehr Nutella, weniger Brot, mehr Lachs, weniger Kartoffeln, mehr Steak, weniger Kartoffelkram, Möhren, Scheiß. Das will niemand. Ich esse auch meistens die Beilagen zuerst auf, um dann das Beste zum Schluss zu haben. Um mich so durchzukämpfen durch Gewalt. Ich kämpfe mich, um dann einfach den Schatz vor mir zu haben, das Azteken-Gold. Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob ich dir da zustimmen würde, ehrlich gesagt, weil gerade also ... Ja, aber du mit deinen Erbsen. Wie ist es da eigentlich weitergegangen? Fand ich auch gut, einen Kommentar, du bist der einzige, der es nicht benutzt, um Wunden zu heilen oder beulen oder sowas, wo man was man erkennt. Eine Hörerin hat geschrieben, ich wusste gar nicht, dass man es essen kann. Ich dachte, man benutzt es nur ausschließlich als tiefgekühlte Erbsen, um Sachen zu sein. Ja, ich bin großer Erbsen-Fan und habe mich auch wieder reingesteigert in die Welt der Erbse. Aber ich bin ja momentan, und vielen Dank an der Stelle auch, denn unsere Hörer kümmern sich ja um uns. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die uns einfach den Gefahren der Welt gegenüber schutzlos dastehen lassen. Nein, niemand hat bei meinem Bootsführerstein gesagt, mach's nicht. Sie werfen sich schützend vor uns. Es ist ja nicht so, dass die uns einfach den Gefahren der Welt gegenüber schutzlos dastehen lassen. Nein. Niemand hat bei meinem Bootsführerschein gesagt, mach's nicht. Sie werfen sich schützend vor uns. Nee. Und eine Hörerin hat mir geschrieben und hat gesagt, pass auf, wenn du viel Spinat isst, musst du dazu auch viel Calcium essen, weil es gibt irgendwie so eine Asonsäure oder irgendwie so eine Säure Klingel. Jetzt ist Spinat für mich gestorben. Ja, Spinat ist tot. Spinat ist nicht geil dafür, dass es einen umbringt.
Fleisch bringt mich um, aber ich mag es halt einfach zu gären.
Es lohnt sich.
Es lohnt sich so, aber Spinat lohnt sich nicht.
Man denkt, man isst Spinat, um gesund zu sein,
und stellt sich raus und meint, Spinat ist die Sünde?
Ja, okay, schau.
Ich dachte, Spinat ist das, was man dagegen arbeitet.
Wir sind wie so Eltern, die uns jetzt verabschieden.
Wir wärmen uns so im Arm und wir winken Spinat zu. Tschüss, Spinat ist das, was man dagegen arbeitet. Wir sind wie so Eltern, die jetzt verabschieden, wir wärmen uns so im Arm und wir winken Spinat zu. Tschüss, wir laufen noch ein Stück neben dem Zug her, wenn Spinat sich verabschiedet. Andere Eltern rennen hinterher, wir gehen noch ein paar Gnadenschritte mit. Ja, genau, ein paar Gnadenschritte. Tschüss, Spinat, Zimmer ist schon ausgeräumt. Und jetzt habe ich mich natürlich auf die Suche gemacht, wie kriegt man gut Calcium und bin jetzt in die wunderbare Welt, also eine extrem aufregende, aber gleichzeitig extrem langweilige Welt eingetaucht, und zwar in die Welt der Mineralwasser. Weil es gibt verschiedene Mineralwasser. So, jetzt wenn du zu viel Wasser trinkst, kannst du auch sterben. Was machst du denn dagegen? Genau, dann hieß es nämlich auch, ja, du brauchst ein Mineralwasserwasser mit hohem Calciumanteil, aber mit einem geringen Nitratanteil oder irgendwie irgendwas anderes, Nitron oder irgendwie sowas. Und dann musste ich auch wieder schön beim Supermarkt meines Vertrauens mal einmal durch die komplette Mineralwasseretage durch mich lesen und wirklich mal die Etiketten konsultieren. und habe jetzt ein Mineralwasser gefunden mit Calcium und habe dann ausgerechnet, weil du brauchst ein, ich glaube, ein Gramm Calcium pro Tag braucht man. Was ist das sehr viel? Und das sind drei Flaschen Mineralwasser. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt jeden Tag drei Flaschen Mineralwasser trinken und denke mir, ich mag Spinat, aber man muss das wirklich. Aber auch gut, dass du jetzt in so einer Kette gefangen bist. Also also du hast mit deiner Spinatflut jetzt was losgetreten, so einen Domino Day-Effekt, dass du jetzt quasi anfangen musst, immer andere Substitute zu essen, die dich aber potenziell auch in den Mengen umbringen können. Kalzium, ihr habt zu viel Kalzium, dann ist da wieder zu viel Nitrat drin. Für Nitrat muss man wieder eisenhaltige Sachen essen, aber wenn man zu viele eisenhaltige Sachen isst, dann muss man da wieder dagegen essen und dagegen kann man wieder gut Spinat essen. Also es ist wirklich ein so großer Kreislaumen, wo man immer... Zu viel Wasser, dann fehlt dem Körper Salz, dann musst du Salz essen und gegen Salz hins Spinat. Und dann bist du irgendwann auch einigermaßen fein. Man taumelt irgendwie diesen Kreis immer wieder ab. Gentot. Langsam gegen Gentot. Es ist eine Spirale Gentot. Es strebt gegen Tod. Und ich bin jetzt gefangen, weil ich komme nicht mehr raus, weil ich hangel mich jetzt von einem defizitären System zum nächsten. Ja, aber wenn du jetzt eine Zutat weglässt, dann war es das sofort. Ich bin gefangen. Ich komme nicht mehr raus. Ich komme nicht mehr raus, Stefan. Ja, aber vielen Dank euch trotzdem, dass ihr ihn bislang noch am Leben gehalten habt. Das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Calcium. Fünfthäufigstes Element der Erde, glaube ich. Also es gibt eine Menge Calcium, aber das ist halt auch irgendwo wieder. Ich finde, ein Gedanke kommt nicht in meinen Kopf. Vielleicht kannst du mir helfen. Warum gibt es so viele verschiedene Wasserhersteller, so Wassermarken? Ja. Weil, aber nur zwei verschiedene Flugzeughersteller. Lass mich elaborieren. Beim Flugzeug gibt es Abermillionen Komponenten. Alles kann anders sein, alles kann anders zusammengestellt sein. Mehr Fenster, weniger Fenster. Ja, hier noch ein Kabel, da ein blaues Kabel, dann ein Flügel. Vier Flügel, zwei Flügel, Doppeldecker. Warum gibt es da nur zwei Hersteller, die sich durchgesetzt haben, die in etwa ähnliche Sachen bauen, aber 50 Milliarden verschiedene Wasserhersteller, die alle H2O verkaufen? Ja, es ist schwierig, vielleicht weil die kürzere Transportgewege haben wollen, Wasser, du willst dann von der lokalen Quelle was beziehen, weil du mehr Wasser brauchst, bei Flugzeug musst du das Ding halt einmal liefern und dann ist gut, aber ich glaube, ich habe es auch nicht ganz verstanden, weil die haben dann so verschiedene Quellen oder so, oder weil die Einstiegshölle halt so gering ist. Ja, kann auch sein. Weil jeder hat schon mal mit Wasser zu tun. Mein Problem war, ich habe da nämlich ein Mineralwasser gefunden, das einen hohen Calciumanteil hatte, aber das war Mondwasser. Wo auf der Flasche drauf stand, das wird nur bei Mondschein abgefüllt, wo ich dachte, das ist doch nicht ein Scheinsterz, ich kann jetzt nicht so einen Esoterik-Quatsch kaufen. Aber ich meine, nur weil da ist Calcium drin, das hat naturwissenschaftlich schon einen Wert, dieses Wasser, aber ich will nicht diese ganze Esoterik-Komponente mit Mond-Ansparen. Du willst nicht zwölf Kästen Mondwasser an der Kasse, auch unangenehm. Ja, nee, das geht nicht. Ich kann da nicht mit einem Kasten Mondwasser gehen, wo irgendwie jede Flasche 30 Cent mehr kostet. Und dann irgendwann bin ich tot und ich stehe vor dem Mondgott und er sagt, toll, dass du immer Mondwasser getrunken hast und ich so, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Leute, Leute, Leute, nein, stopp. Also, ich muss noch mal wirklich, sorry, komplett von vorne anfangen. Ihr habt das alles falsch verstanden. Nochmal, Johnny Depp ist... Ich habe das... Ja, Johnny Depp ist ein ehrenvoller, äh, äh, äh, also ich möchte nichts sagen und ich habe das Mondwasser getrunken, weil es Calcium hatte, nicht wegen der Mondkomponente. Und der Mondgott so, was? Mit seinem grossen Auge. Der Mond mit seinem grossen, wachen Auge. Nein, tut mir leid, Mond, das ist doch jetzt nichts gegen dich. Mond, jetzt mach doch jetzt kein Regengesicht. Mond macht ein Regengesicht? Mir ging es doch nur darum, weil ich halt nicht glaube, dass du bist halt zu klein und so weit weg. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass du wirklich einen Einfluss hast auf die Qualität. Du willst doch auch nicht, dass man mit deinem Namen billig Geld verdient.
Du willst auch nicht, dass dein Name ausgenutzt wird. Ich war immer auf deiner Seite bei dieser ganzen Monddiskussion,
bei Mondgate.
Ich war immer auf deiner Seite, dass der Schlaf nicht beeinflusst.
Weil ich immer dachte, ja gut, ist ja schon egal,
ob der Mond heller ist oder dunkler.
Das hat ja nicht mehr Einfluss.
Klar, hat der Mond Einfluss auf die Erde, Tiden, Gezeiten.
Ich bin da jetzt voll im Thema drin.
Aber ja nicht, wenn er, Leute können nicht schlafen, wenn Mond Vollmond hat, das macht ja keinen Sinn, weil dann die Anziehungskraft dann nicht stärker ist.
Stellt sich raus, doch, die Gezeiten sind häufig dann bei Vollmond oder wie heisst der Mond, wenn er ganz weg ist, das jedenfalls, da sind die Gezeiten auch am höchsten, weil Gezeiten haben ja auch Unterschiede, die flutrieren ja auch und die größten Unterschiede zwischen Ebbe und Flut hast du bei Vollmond. Aber meinst du wirklich, dass Leute, die sagen, man kann bei Vollmond nicht schlafen, denken deswegen der erhöhten Mondanziehungskraft?
Nee, ich möchte nur gerade die Frage stellen. Ich habe bislang immer gedacht, ja gut, Vollmond hat ja keinen technischen, bis auf die Helligkeit und das Marginal, keinen Einfluss auf unser tägliches Leben hier auf der Erde. Okay, du sagst das mit der Anziehungskraft. Das einzige, was ich dem Mond zuschreiben wollte, war halt, gut, du kannst mit deiner Anziehungskraft die Gezeiten beeinflussen. Tolle Nummer, Mond. Und warum ist der höher, wenn er Vollmond ist? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich, weil er dann zur Erde so steht, dass da Gezeiten ... Aber die Entfernung ändert sich doch nicht bei Vollmond. Das ist doch nur wie die Sonne von die Gezeitenkalender. Wenn du einen Gezeitenkalender von der Nordsee dir anguckst, dann ist der bei Vollmond und dem, wo er am wenigsten zu sehen ist, sind die Gezeiten am krassten. Die Unterschiede zwischen Elbe und Flut sind sind am krassen. Und da hast du nicht deinen Kapitänslehrer gefragt, warum das so ist? Ging nicht. Ich mache so einen Online-Kurs und ich habe ihn angebrüllt, aber es war nicht so, dass er da aufgeregt hätte. Das ist in den Textfeld geschrieben, ja, aber warum, das hat doch nichts mit der Anziehung zu tun. Warum hat das auch keinen Sinn? Ne, aber vielleicht, weil da ist ja die Sonne dann auf der anderen Seite der Erde. Ja, das meine ich nämlich. Entweder das, oder es ist bei der Nordsee halt einfach ein Zufall. Das kann ja auch sein. Ja, aber glaubst du an Zufälle? Glaubt ein Seemann an Zufälle? Ein Seemann glaubt zumindest nicht, dass er die See bezwingen kann. Ist das die richtige Antwort? Ich denke auch nur so in Multiple-Choice-Dingern.
Ja, genau.
Ich weiß nicht viel über Seefahren,
ich weiß nur, was die drei falschen Antworten sind. Genau, ich weiß auch nicht, was die richtige Antwort ist,
aber ich bin gut darin zu sehen, welche Antwort ausgedacht ist.
Nee, manchmal, vor allem wenn man so lernt,
ich habe auch dieses alte Fahrschulding wieder,
man klickt halt manchmal automatisch auf Antworten,
ohne die Frage durchzulesen,
weil man sich die Muster der Antwort gemerkt hat. Ja. Und so lerne ich jetzt. Ich bin später verloren. Ich werde auf jeden Fall auf dem Boot sterben. Ja, es kann sein. Und dann wird deine Leiche für immer am Grund des Bodens liegen und vergessen. Und weißt du was? Cooler als ein Spinat. Es ist cooler, auf Wasser zu sterben als ein Spinat. Kannst du denn nicht sagen, dass ein Seefahrtsunglück cooler ist als der Spinat-Tod? Natürlich!
Der quälende Spinat-Tod, der mich ereilen wird.
Ist der Schlimmste, sagen alle. Aber ich glaube, es ist cooler und spektakulärer, auf See zu sterben.
Die See hat ihn zu sich geholt, sagt man ja.
Gesunken.
Zack, gesunken.
Einfach gegen so eine Boje gefahren, gegen so einen Wal gefahren und gesunken.
Ach, Wale, ey.
Wie viele Schiffe auf dem Meeresboden noch liegen müssen, oder?
Ja, und das ist das Geilste an dieser Karte.
Und da war eine Frage dann plötzlich, 1,2 Seemalien südwestlich von dem Ziel, was die an Zeit geht, sind zwei Sachen eingezeichnet, was ist das?
Und dann steht da W, K, das ist ein Wracks, Schiffwracks.
Und du siehst halt einfach in der Nordsee, du hast überall Schiffwracks.
Aber aus welcher Zeit ist das dann alles?
Meistens Erster und Zweiter Weltkrieg.
Aber du hast Milliarden Schiffwracks, so um Helgoland rum und ostfische Inseln.
Aber wie tief sind die in der Regel?
53 Meter.
53 Meter, das ist ja gar nichts.
Ja, und das war so relativ weit draußen.
Und Richtung Ufer hast du dann einfach mal so sechs Meter. In sechs Meter Tiefe ist ein Wrack von einem Weltkriegsschiff. Schiffswracks. Ja, und tauchst du da nicht hin? Ich habe ja mit viel getaucht. Wobei ich jetzt auch nicht weiß, ob das dann ein Weltkriegsschiff ist. Aber dieses sechs Meter Wrack ist, glaube ich, kein Weltkriegsschiff. Das ist einfach so ein Hobby-Katamaran. Ja, so ein Schlauchboot, ein Dingi. So ein Schwan-Tretboot, das da liegt, dass sich die doch alle angucken und da einmal durchtauchen. Genau, so ein Tretboot. Aber so Schiffwracks, bevor wir da hin, wenn ich meinen Schein habe, dann machen wir mal die grosse Schiffwrack-Tür. Genau, wir wollten ja eh das Podcast UFO-Abenteuer durchziehen, haben wir auch noch nicht gemacht. Mal nach Gold suchen oder mal irgendwie so Skelette bergen oder so was am Schiff. Ja, aber wir, und das wäre doch Antenne ala Bastia, Entenne Aztekengold, aber mal wirklich zur Spitze getrieben. Wir beiden suchen einen echten Schatz. Wir sind die grossen Flutter-Karibik-Fans, die grössten in der deutschen Podcast-Landschaft. Moment, aber ist nicht die Kernbotschaft von Flutter-Karibik, dass der Schatz dich am Ende eher unglücklicher macht, wenn der verflucht ist? Nee, dass wir unser Schatz sind, dass der Podcast unser Schatz, dass der ganze Zeit schon bei uns war. Das ist die Lektion. Dass du mein Schatz bist. Aber wenn wir die Moral jetzt schon haben, warum müssen wir dann noch das Abenteuer machen? Ja, das ist das Problem, wir sind zu weit. Wir sind schon durch sind schon durch. Abenteuer anzugehen ist ja nichts Cleveres. Bist du denn nicht abenteuerlustig zumindest? Und ganz ehrlich, ich will schon so einen Schatz finden. Ja, ich will auch einen Schatz finden, aber die Frage ist halt, ob wir als Leidende hingauen können, wo schon ganz viele Leute sind. Oder ob wir Informationen haben, die andere Leute nicht haben. Ja, da müssen wir einfach unsere Schwarmintelligenz nutzen. Jetzt? Fische meinst du? Fische und unser Publikum. Ach so. Im Sinne von, vielleicht können die uns Informationen zuspielen und für die jetzt andere Seefahrer die Kenntnisse nicht haben, aber und dann können wir vielleicht mal das Bernsteinzimmer finden. Ich meine, ich habe noch eine Schatzsuche in meinem Zimmer, in meinem Wohnzimmer zur Verfügung.
Wenn ich damit durch bin, könnt ihr uns ja mal zuhauchen.
Mach du erst mal deinen Goldzahn.
Ich habe da eine Kiste Gold, leider ist mir über die Reling gekommen, aus Versehen leider.
Das war irgendwo zwischen da und da.
Sowas wäre gut, sowas wäre richtig gut.
Ey, wir finden das, wir finden einen Goldschatz.
Es gibt ja auch so diese großen Containerschiffe und da gab es auch mal den Fall, dass da ein paar Container über Bord gegangen sind und gesunken sind. Und dann gibt es jetzt so einen Strand in England, wo halt ständig Lego angespült wird. Oh mein Gott, yes! Weil da war ein riesiger Container mit Lego-Bausteinen und an diesem Strand wird halt ständigändig Lego angespült, halt jahrelang, immer.
Weil da muss so viel Lego untergegangen
sein, dass du da halt wirklich
über den Strand laufen kannst und da Legosteine
aufsammeln kannst. Hat man ja mal
geguckt, was die Fische damit so machen?
Ob die Delfine irgendwie so coole ... Oh, das weiß ich nicht.
Und vor allem das Tollste ist, dass
das gesamte Lego auch noch
Seefahrtsmotive hat.
Also da sind dann Angeln drin und
Tintenfische und es war irgend so ein
Seefahrerset oder so,
das halt da untergegangen ist.
Es ist halt perfekt.
Da sind halt kleine Boote, es ist halt
so niedlich. Aber es ist weird,
wenn so ein Strandset angespült wird, plötzlich
am Strand und die Kinder so
what is happening?
Und dann sieht das Kind sich selbst auch auf der Verpackung unten als Lego.
Aber als Eltern würde ich sagen, ja, hier leben kleine Menschen. Hier leben kleine Menschen und das sind halt so ein Beachball für die kleinen Menschen.
Und dann denken die Kinder, da leben wirklich kleine Menschen. Aber es ist tatsächlich ein bisschen weniger romantisch, als man denkt, weil es ist halt einfach alles vollgemüllt.
Wie die meisten Strände sind einfach alles vollgemüllt in Plastik und deshalb geht halt auch noch ein paar hunderttausend Jahre so. Aber dann ist alles weg. Dann ist auch gut. Naja, wir müssen bis dahin halt aufhören, Plastik in die Umwelt, in die Weltmeere zu stecken. Wenn ich irgendwie Hersteller von so Chips wäre oder so, so Pringles und die zeigen dann so Panorama von diesen Müllbergen, wenn ich mir, bitte keine Pringles-Dose, bitte bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, zoom jetzt nicht. Chips frisch. Zoom die auch noch so direkt auf Chips frisch. Ungarisch. Chips frisch, Ungarisch. Und alle in der Zentrale. Nein, nimm doch Chio, fuck. Genau unsere. Und wir können da ja gar nichts für, es ist ausgerechnet unsere im Müll. Ja, oder auch immer, wenn so ein Fisch verendet am Strand und so eingeklemmt ist, irgendwie in so eine Dose und bei Pepsi, bitte nicht Pepsi, bitte nicht Pepsi und halt so. Seven Up. Yes! Seven Up Zero und im anderen Gebäude so, nein, die ganze Kampagne. Direkt nebenan. Das stimmt, man hofft wirklich, dass es das nicht ist. Ich stelle mir immer vor, dass sie da so ein Live-Feed bekommen und dann immer so extrem emotional dabei sind. Aber es ist schwierig, ja. Ja, das ist ja eine Selusie vor. Also ein kleines Kind, die kleine Annabelle ist erstickt, weil sie am Strand gespielt hat und sie ist reingefallen in eine Waschmaschine und dann kam sie nicht mehr raus.
Und diese Waschmaschine die neue 5H von Bosch mit trockener Funktion.
Nein!
Fuck.
Muss man wirklich aufpassen, mit Waschmaschinen ist es tatsächlich ein Problem, wenn du Waschmaschinen einfach so in den Wald wirfst oder so, kann es sein, dass da Kinder reinkrabbeln, die Tür zu machen und nicht mehr aufkriegen.
Oh Gott.
Weil die Waschmaschinen gehen ja von innen nicht auf.
Oh mein Gott. Und das ist wirklich ein Problem. Wer stellt denn Waschmaschinen, viele Fragen, wer stellt Waschmaschinen in den Wald? Die einfach keinen Bock haben, da zu, also entweder wollen die, ist es so eine Art Eichhörnchenkomplex oder die haben ja keinen Bock, zum Wettstoff aufzuhören. Deswegen, falls ihr das tut, bitte macht da irgendwie die Sicherung raus. Aber was passiert mit allen Waldwaschmaschinen?
Wo kommen die hin? Ich habe jetzt auch in meinem Alter
entsorgen, also da wird die mitgenommen
und die neue wird hingestellt.
Wo bringen die die hin? Ich glaube, das ist gängig,
dass die vergraben werden im Wald, also dass
die wirklich einfach da hingeworfen werden oder
in einem Garten. Wo lang alle Dinge?
Hatte ich ja auch einen Freund bei mir in der Schule,
wo einfach Sachen im Garten vergraben
wurden, die weg sollten, weil die wollten,
die hatten einfach keinen Bock da zum Wettstoffhof zu fahren
Vielen Dank. Also kenne ich ja auch alle Dinge. Hatte ich ja auch einen Freund bei mir in der Schule, wo einfach Sachen im Garten vergraben wurden, die weg sollten, weil die wollten, die hatten einfach keinen Bock da zum Wärtschorfhof zu fahren oder so und haben dann einfach die alten Spülmaschinen einfach im Garten vergraben. Und ich denke da immer an Archäologen, die halt, für die das Gefundene Fressen ist, die halt in 10.000 Jahren. Gefundene Waschmaschinen. Die das finden und denken, ach, die ist doch ganz gut. Die kann nur lösen. Die ist auch noch in Ordnung, die ist doch super. Wo sind denn alle Dinge, ist auch eine alte Jerry Seinfeld-Frage, wo sind alle Kugelschreiber zum Beispiel? Weil es gibt so viele Kugelschreiber, überall werden die verkauft, man hat selber schon in seinem Leben so viele gehabt, mal alle wieder verloren, wo sind die denn alle hin? Da müsste man eigentlich mal so nachfragen bei so Big oder so, die solche Wegwerfgegenstände, aber auch die, ja, wir produzieren jeden Tag zehntausend Feuerzeuge und wo landen die denn? Wo sind die alle? Sie müssen hier draufdrücken und dann kommt die Flamme, Sie können hier vorne mit dem Regler einstellen, große Flamme, kleine Flamme, ich weiß nicht genau, wie Feuerzeuge funktionieren. Hier, bitteschön, den schenke ich Ihnen. Viel Spaß. Wo sind sie alle? Wo sind sie alle? Dann wird an den Schultern geschüttelt und gefragt. Die Kamera wackelt, weil Mikrofon im Bild. Was freut mich bei so vielen Dingen, wo landen diese ganzen Dinge? Im Meer. Ich habe es dir gerade gesagt, im Endeffekt landen die alle an irgendeinem Strand und irgendein Kind hat dann das Feuerzeug in der Hand. Es landet alles im Meer, wirklich alles im Meer. Ja, ne? Alles fließt immer ins Meer. Muss ich jetzt auch noch ins Meer, ist die Frage. Müllhalde der Welt. Muss ich da jetzt auch noch rumschippern im Meer? Vor allem, du verdrängst ja auch Wasser, du erhöhst ja den Meer, wenn du da mit einem Schiff rumfährst. Und das ganze Müll, den wir ins Meer schmeißen, erhöht auch den Meeresspiegel. Darf man nicht ins Meer schmeißen? Ja gut, sag das mal Lego oder Chio. In der Prüfungsaufgabe steht, man soll sich an die zehn goldenen Regeln für Seefahrer halten. Das ist immer die richtige Antwort bei allen Umweltfragen. Und ehrlich gesagt will ich dann auch die Prüfungskommission mal jetzt zu Rate ziehen und sagen, wenn man nur lernen muss bei Umweltschutz, dass alle Antworten mit zehn goldenen Regeln richtig ist, ist es vielleicht nicht die beste Art, diesen Text zu formulieren, diesen Test zu formulieren.
Ja, das ist genau wie in der Fasche, wo du auch immer schreibst, ja, rücksichtsvoll und vorausschauend fahren. Genau. Wie müssen sie sich hier verhalten? Rücksichtsvoll und vorausschauend? Rücksichtsvoll und vorausschauend? Ja, das ist technisch gesehen richtig selbstverständlich. Und da vorne ist jemand halbtot geköpft worden auf seinem Motorrad. Was machen sie jetzt? Rücksichtsvoll und vorausschauend. Nein, sie helfen dem! Ach so, rücksichtsvoll und vorausschauend helfen. Ja. Ich bin ja durch meine Theorieprüfung durchgefallen. Oh mein Gott, ich habe so Angst. Es ist mir nicht peinlich, das zuzugeben. Theorieversager unite, ihr seid keine Unmenschen. Ich habe es auch gemacht, ich bin einer von euch, die durch die Theorieprüfung gefallen ist. Ich hätte zehn von elf Fehlerpunkten und es war perfekt. Ich erinnere mich sogar noch an die Frage, die mir das Genick gebrochen hat, und zwar, was bedeutet ein A auf einem Lastwagen? Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, du bist schlau, schau dir die Multiple-Choice-Antworten an, wir kommen da durch, wir schaffen das gemeinsam. Kommt man nicht übrigens! Ich habe meinem Gehirn den Arm um die Schulter gelegt und habe gesagt, komm, wir haben schon eine Menge durcherlebt, wir haben schon eine Länge gemeistert, wir kriegen das hin.
Und dann war zur Auswahl Abfalltransport, atomarer Transport, also irgendwie Atommüll oder sowas, und dann glaube ich noch chemisch brennbare Substanzen oder sowas. Und ich dachte mir, gut, als Autofahrer ist mir egal, ob da Müll drin ist oder nicht, wohingegen, wenn da Atommüll transportiert wird, denke ich mir, gut, den vielleicht mal nicht von der Spur abdrängen, vielleicht, und habe das angekreuzt. Falsche Antwort, richtige Antwort ist tatsächlich Müll. Wo ich mir denke, das ist mir doch völlig egal. Ist nicht A auf allen? Also ich glaube, also vielleicht wahrscheinlich erinnere ich es jetzt falsch, aber ich erinnere mich noch, dass es ein spezielles Zeichen für Mülltransport gab oder Abfall für A oder sowas.
Und ich mir wirklich damals auch während der Prüfung. Also ich glaube, also vielleicht, wahrscheinlich erinnere ich es, wird es falsch, aber ich erinnere mich noch, dass es ein spezielles Zeichen für Mülltransport gab oder Abfall für A oder sowas.
Und ich mir wirklich damals auch während der Prüfung dachte, das kann nicht sein, das interessiert mich nicht. Mich interessiert grundsätzlich nicht, was in den Lastwagen drin ist. Aber da dachte, und so das weiß ich noch genau, da dachte ich, ich komme da mit Menschenverstand durch und nein, habe ich nicht geschafft. Ja, ich erzähle ja immer, wenn ich gefragt werde, ob ich an Gott glaube, meine Theorieprüfung, weil das war wirklich eine göttliche Fügung in dem Moment. Das ist ja, das war Wahnsinn, das war ja an PCs und die Chance, dass neben einem die gleiche Frage, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Fragen es gibt, aber die Chance, dass derjenige neben einem sitzt, zum gleichen Zeitpunkt diese Frage bekommt, ist bei eins zu einer Million oder so. Und du konntest abschauen, oder was? Und ich wusste, ich habe zehn Fehlerpunkte, man darf maximal zehn haben. Und ich wusste, die Frage, die jetzt kam, wusste ich auch nicht. Das ist die letzte Frage gewesen. Wie viele Badewannen braucht man, um einen Tropfen Öl zu verdünnen, was man im Spassendenverkehr natürlich braucht. Und ich wusste es nicht mehr. Und dann gucke ich nach links und da saß halt ein Typ neben mir und da hatte die gleiche Frage, wusste sofort die Antwort. Und ich so, what, habe ich einfach auch angeklickt, war richtig. Und da habe ich mit zehn vier letzten Punkten noch so gerade bestanden. Und das erzähle ich, da habe ich zum Beispiel, ich habe mit dem Pfarrer gesprochen, und ein Pfarrer hat geschrieben, ob ich an Gott glaube, da habe ich diese glaube. Nein! Da habe ich diese Geschichte erzählt. Und er hat gesagt, ja, das ist Gott.
Ach komm, das muss doch selbst einem Pfarrer zu blöd sein. Und dann dachte ich mir,
das ist das Einzige, was mir einfiel,
und dann meinte er, ja, das ist Gott.
Dann habe ich gesagt, mega cool Gott.
Ja, aber was ist das denn für ein Gott,
der dich durch die Dinge, die du nicht weißt
und die Prüfung nicht bestehen solltest,
dich trotzdem durch die Prüfung bringt?
Ja, und dann habe ich fünf Kinder überfahren und weiss nicht, wie viel ich mein Öl verdinnen soll. Das ist mein Gott. Und dann habe ich auch zum Pfarrer gesagt, wenn das Gott ist, I'm a big fan. Komm mir in, komm mir in. Spricht er noch nicht für den Abraham-Moses-Gott? Geben Sie mir Ihren Formular. Könnte auch Vishnu sein. Wo muss ich unterschreiben? Er meinte, das ist Gott. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, wenn das Gott ist, bin ich Fan. Mega-Gott. So ein cooler Gott, so ein cooler Lehrer, der immer so sagt, ja komm, ja komm, was schon bestanden, würde ich sagen. Oder lass ihn auf die Strasse, der ist jung, der muss fahren, der muss fahren, der muss auf die Strasse, der muss mit seinem Peugeot 305 CC. Das ist kein Mann des Stillstands. Supergott, ehrlich gesagt, Megagott. Gut, ich mein, klar, die Abraham-Nummer, Abraham-Isaac war ein Downer. Das weiss Gott ja auch selbst. Mittlerweile hilft er uns. Meinst du, der hat Reue gezeigt? Gibt's einen Moment in der Bibel, wo Gott sagt, sorry, also das ... Sorry, sorry, Entschuldigung, noch mal sorry. Ihr habt das völlig ... Also, Johnny ... Also, ich habe auch einen Fehler gemacht, aber der Johnny, das ist ein guter. Also jetzt seid mal nicht so hart zu dem. Ich bin auf jeden Fall sehr froh, dass ich bestanden habe und möchte aber diese Prüfungssituation nicht mehr haben. Aber ich habe Sonntag meine theoretische Prüfung und ich bin sehr aufgeregt und und muss noch lernen. Wir werden nächste Woche erfahren, ob du dich gut geschlagen hast. Wenn ich es nicht erwähne, bin ich durchgefallen. Und wir werden sehen, ich wünsche dir natürlich alles Gute, viel Erfolg, viel Glück, gut Ahoi, gut Fahrt, gut Wind. Immer eine Handweit Wasser unterm Kiel, muss ich sagen. Immer eine Handweit Wasser unterm Kiel. Ein bisschen flüssiger vielleicht.
Immer drei Knoten Wasser
im... dass deinen
Feinden die Flaute
beschert sein will. Ja, danke.
Wir sehen uns auch nächste Woche, haut rein.
Gut Segel, gut Wind wünschen wir euch.
Vielen Dank nochmal an Druckloch für dieses fantastische
Intro. Wir haben jetzt wirklich
einige super Intros bekommen. Da merkt man mal, es lohnt sich, euch ins Gewissen zu reden und wirklich mal gute Intros rauszuhauen.
Die Peitsche rauszuhauen.
Freut euch auf die nächsten Folgen, es wird grossartig, ansonsten habt eine fantastische Woche, haut rein und macht's gut, ciao.
Ciao!
Stefan! Ich habe Schmerzen.
Stefan, West Bird!